hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to I am bread a game by the
developers of surgeon simulator and you
can obviously see the connection between
the two games I literally know nothing
about this game
they sent me a tweet message saying hey
you want to code to our game I said I
had no idea what it's about but sure
considering how much I loved surgeon
simulator and love doing it my guess is
to some bread so here we go I've okay
dr. Merton spent most of the session
talking about his past mainly focusing
on the failed business mertens merchants
and the subsequent divorce of his wife
Barbara Barbara he moved on to
threatening the council again as well as
the local carpet world the session ended
with him angrily saying that he was
going shopping with attention to eat
himself to death he appears to be
dealing with multiple stress points and
focusing all the anger towards council
to which he claims they are responsible
with the downfall of his business I
believe him now employed by the council
as a street cleaner exacerbating the
issue I believe doesn't that he accepts
at this time the things are not going
his way but a positive outlook is
imperative we have another session
booked for tomorrow the shopping ripping
she's making the mind off the event
while I review some of the potential
solutions okay you come toast oh god oh
god no what how what an ability an
ability what am I even doing Oh God
you oh you ha ha ha ha ha ha even I
don't understand what I'm trying to do
ok so if I press qwe are they like
toggle I've got a grip thing here what
do you want from me game how do I even
move what am i doing with my life
they do nothing ok oh I need to use them
in combination war in the world oh so
it's like it oh god ok I'm getting I'm
getting of a guy alright ah my head
ability is falling Oh No wouldn't want
that to happen
who's gonna eat me anyway this is gonna
be the sad life of me trying to cheer up
that guy who ever was really
disappointed with something
okay yeah I get it but go oh god it's so
bad oh come on
- I gotta like rotate on the fulcrums
use them as platform suited oh god is so
bad okay so if I can grab on that I can
swing myself up using ah ah I did it I
don't know I'm so happy about uh yeah
okay so I can let go now
I can head this flip over there flip
over on the three okay well I screwed up
yeah no come on back how how how how
[ __ ] it's a [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah ah
god damn you Daniel ah go [ __ ] this game
like a [ __ ] this red god dammit why did
you make a game those even harder to
control fun okay there's nothing nothing
that infuriates me more than bad
controls and the one thing that I got so
goddamn angry about insurgent simulator
was that the controls sucked
alright why why make it more bad okay
whatever this is calm down think of the
kittens or whatever think of some cute
kittens berry add some kittens in I want
kittens you better give me kittens okay
so alright I got this uh-huh at least
the music's banging okay so I need to
not go that way whoa whoa whoa we are a
grip grip laughs [ __ ] [ __ ] piss ass
balls I got bones in me Oh OOP OOP OOP
go please okay now just let me
cute there we go okay going the wrong
way though something to go that way need
to go let go that one you go yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah I don't know what I'm
doing but yeah yeah yeah yeah okay how
did how does that physics how do you
even explain that one I should have
known so simple now okay this doesn't
make any goddamn sense hey uh you said
are you started up a screw Everett nope
nope no no no no no no no nope no I
don't want to quick to the main menu of
course I don't want to quit
what are you doing I don't want to quit
I don't want to share this [ __ ] your
is broken it's broken
this is here it's broken won't let me go
restart so I just got sandier while it
fails great okay here we go again
this time I'm gonna have a positive
attitude positivity is everything you
need to have a positive attitude in life
otherwise you're just gonna get a hernia
and die and then you're gonna get a
blood clot in your brain and then it's
gonna explode and then you're never
gonna be happy again say god Bryce
happiness where it is god that noise is
so annoying
why did they intent nope why do they
intentionally pick the most annoying
sound possible what is this supposed to
be impossible how am I gonna get there
in time slippy dude dude let me do how
the Frick attract like there's no grip
option now there's no grip there's no
grip there's no grip option Oh screw my
life screw my life Raven is this bull
can't do one goddamn thing yeah yeah
yeah yup there you go yeah yep yep
[ __ ] you yeah [ __ ] yay yay it's won't
let me crimp ah so ops in the grip
yeah what's up how is that possible I
didn't know I could do that
alright then that changes a lot of
things I didn't know I could go straight
up a wall where black magic is this I
thought I had to have a grip oh that is
the grip oh oh okay that oh yeah I get
it I get it I'm doing bad I know
come on get up swing up there whoa whoa
this is totally mounting your friends
right now yeah okay
help come on yep come on none of time
swing up you douche ah
Frigga frack oh god I'm almost there ah
okay swing up grant swing up swing up
swing up swing up okay swing up swing up
swing up I'm getting good at this
after all that trial and tribulation
I'll finally be good at something come
on you douche no no oh god damn it you
son of a [ __ ] you piece of [ __ ] I can't
believe you you almost did that to me me
one of those larvae ill I gotta get all
the way to the toaster for the fricken I
got 16 percent at a bit at all
come right in the larva the bugs
whatever the ants whatever you know what
I'm in got that music I freakin hate
that turn down the goddamn music is
annoying is free of rack hate that music
oh now it just went away completely good
maybe that's the cut that's boring now
you backed up in a broken game broken
broken game broken games
let go let go just no oh god no go down
down down now get up get up get up get
up get up huh broken game broken game
why do I play these games games hi don't
care about anything I'm gonna fall cuz
stupid piece of [ __ ] won't grab to the
finger [ __ ] ass hey come on
just obey me Oh God
hi this where I get a hernia this is
where I lose everything in my little bit
of sanity that I have left
cuz this won't fricking I'm not gonna
make it I'm not gonna make it I'm not
gonna make it
Oh get up there get grab on to something
No oh let's just take a breather
everybody the second breather stretch it
out flex swim no yeah [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
God piece of [ __ ] I'm getting the swing
of things I'm getting used to these
things even though it's awful getting
used to it don't a wild one don't know
why I'd wanna build this as a skill in
my daily life why do I need to know how
to do any of this why do I need any of
this in anything at all why would I why
would I ever why would I ever want to
have this skill in my gaming repertoire
guy into the toaster over there
I can either cross the valley of death
Oh for the best let's cry that's what
I'm doing
screw you everybody now you all up there
watching just to screw everything you
know just no no no no no no no no no
come on sit up [ __ ] it's not the
easiest thing in the world guys in fact
it's quite stupid
just okay just okay okay okay get up
okay
get up quickly quickly quickly quickly
quickly quickly quickly quickly quickly
okay yay dick Hey oh [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
[ __ ] everything about you oh wait this
game I hate it so much I hate it up what
are you doing what are you doing how are
you okay I don't understand what just
happened just okay do I have to push the
switch there is that why it's red cuz
that would I have to do why is this so
hard now I'm right here I'm stuck I'm
literally stuck right now are you
kidding me do I have to slot oh [ __ ] yo
dad just okay come on please okay here
we go here we go let's get in there it's
going one doing no come on come on
play play play anymore flee what does
this even mean this is even mean okay
how am I gonna get out of this okay okay
god damn it god damn what the hell why
am i half burnt like that it's not good
enough no that's not good enough of
course not why no God no God no stop
stop oh [ __ ] okay all right okay all
right okay I'm not playing it anymore
I'm never playing this game of goddamn
again because this is the most
infuriating experience I've ever had in
my entire life okay
think of kittens think of puppies never
play this game thank you very much for
watching if you want to see me rage out
to more crap as a surgeon simulator
playlist there's more awesome games and
I've reached to down there below just go
us them they're at least fun thank you
all so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos yeah as
always I'll see you in the next video
bye bye OH
forget out no good
I got it continue with the bouncing
study ah ah design a bed